hello and welcome back to whiskey me
drinking whiskey I am joined here today
with famous Irishman mr. penis face it's
me your real name this time I know out
of character today we're gonna drink
some whiskey and we're also shooting in
front of a live audience so since you're
Irish yeah obviously raka holics well
and also we're gonna drink some Irish
whiskey oh that's where we going
one thing that kinda unifies Irish
whiskey is it's not very peaty it's not
it's not very PG which is contrary to
what youth the whiskey you gave yes very
PD I thought it was like the only thing
it had no it's actually in the opposite
so Irish whiskey typically you don't
want to drink when like ice or anything
like that no you want to drink it
straight up because it's already very
light and very nice well we'll see about
okay let's say well why don't we start
with the Jameson the class this is one
of the most famous whiskey brands
football of town you guys recognize the
Jameson this is like the cheap ones it's
the one will you mix it with ginger ale
typically yeah I'm just gonna for a
little bit cuz we have a lot of whiskey
to go apparently James Jamison Jamison
Jamison people calling that Chuck Norris
of whiskey I don't know why they just
think he's a badass he apparently is a
Scotsman Oh fraud yeah I think he moved
into Ireland to do this distillery get
to learn how to spell it a different way
that I don't know yes what is he in
Ireland its launch its launch and why I
went there
its launch aboard at a 50 gold it's not
good joke I like it
statistic whiskey why don't we step it
up a notch I and this one I know nothing
well as an Irishman I can tell you it's
it's not very expensive I made this one
find the ocean oh why did they do that
girl's gonna eat these why does anybody
pack anything with these it's so
annoying right tell us what you smell
vanilla top note that's a very easy to
drink whiskey so kids out there if you
want to get my god yeah you're right
start with the Irish with him that was
that like a kid's whiskey yeah well yeah
that was nice
next up we have the whiskey that yeah
connemara they all karemera you give to
me this whisk I did
oh this is the cheaper version yeah it's
still nice stuff Connemara
fun fact chimeras one of the places in
Harlan that still speaks very heavy
Gaelic this is the last thing I drank
before I got stomach flu stomach
sickness
oh yeah and after it I was just like I
couldn't drink whiskey for so long you
can't you ruined it for me
this one might mess you up and this one
also comes packed with that so this one
is peated yeah so why don't you tell
everyone about
pedan waste-heat well peace or turf do
you know what penis yeah
but I used to live next to it oh I used
to live next to a ball game love cavitus
so right next to my house is a peat bog
so he's basically like dirty DK yes yeah
I think what you dig up to burn in your
fire well let's have a look let's go
with there when live in a fancy one yeah
so these are made so that you can smell
it better
oh sorry we're doing this now it's do it
mr. oak the flavours mr. science over
okay you have you know what mr. fancy
okay Irish people just drink it that's
good I like that
yep it's a lot more flavor yeah the
other ones I don't know if you can drink
too much of it though it's nice I do
like it if you prefer like smoky time
it's good it's bolder has a bit of body
to it risky Baker I didn't know you
smelled this night look at this fancy
box by the way ceiling so I don't risk
it did really badly for a long time he
used to be super popular and then it did
really badly and this is the first
distillery in Dublin that opening
hundred 25 years
oh wow you get a certificate as well I
guess yeah Jack teaming jack'd healing
has signed this whiskey thank you jack
this is a crazy bottle by the way look
at this it's very clear 1999 it's 14
years old I'm gonna I'm gonna swirl the
glass I don't know if you know this you
swirl the glass cuz it invokes the smell
well yeah well the thing is
cuz it's been in there for a long time
and you wanna you know think goes on
tops you want to mix it it smells like
something and I don't know what it is
yeah it's kind of hard to describe I
understand like a manly perfume I don't
know let's just drink it okay
bottoms up that's a weird one that's
very different from the others yeah kind
of balances on your mouth it balances
all around in my mouth right now it's
very different very nice is that it
no way okay sorry you just looked at me
like okay what next redbreast oh I wish
is a prayer you know this yeah this is
what you wanna do this
it's weird with water and there's a
strong affinity to foot 200
I like how I said we he said you yeah
you put too much water you kind of
ruined it then I think everyone's gonna
get pissed at it okay thanks
I have been jacksepticeye there is more
whiskey Jack come back say that this one
was their most expensive line well I
don't really know what it is so it's
made by the whiskey agency which I
imagine it's just like a group of people
whose their bottling what they like to
drink to still in our own age 27 years
distilled that's as old as I am yeah
that's pretty cool you know what they
say you know you're it's a privilege to
drinking whiskey as old as you are
okay this is that's just like all of a
sudden like like pierced my nose i don't
ii [ __ ] it no it's very nice
so what i'm told you can do is you get a
like a couple drops of water and that
will make the chemical reaction of the
whiskey go they will hit your tongue the
flavor I think I've formulated that sins
quite eloquently thank you very much Wow
my god that's like the teething one look
like oh I like that one way stronger
damn if it's only so damn it bites you
man it's almost like a hit your tongue
and then just like spreads out yeah like
I want a lot sitting still maybe that
was worth the price I would say that was
definitely the best one that's a strong
whiskey yeah I'm not too impressed with
that but I just did so fruity but it's
even though it's so strong and still has
so it's sort of contrast that it has so
much alcohol in it that was it
what's it that was a just kidding we
have one more I was just present that
was a good one to leave often we have oh
my god this looks like moonshine this
whiskey is vintage kober dose it's
covered in test guess how all this I
don't know well the other one was 27
years so I'm assuming it's more than
that okay give me and give me a number
come on just 35 okay wait no one in the
audience one of gifts okay with you then
you don't get 48 there is something hey
I was gonna say 50 originally but I
thought that was too high any other
guesses 75 it's a hundred years old
what it's from 1920 so it's almost a
hundred Jesus I don't know if I'm
supposed to open it because it's kind of
like it's that what you do or do you
just keep it or like uh whiskey channels
you're the one who watches that's it
well that's the thing I don't know I
never seen anyone have like a really
really really old with 70 proof as well
are we gonna die drink that is basically
absinthe what's that it's your birthday
whiskey might as well be your death day
as well whiskey's we're drinking right
yeah yeah oh my god I barely put any
pressure on that and I should have
thought about it before I did it
what's the point of having that old
who's chief you can't even open it says
70 proof on it this is way older than
the summer was combined in the room this
smells like someone's burnt down house
doesn't it yeah it smells like a burnt
down house it's cool cool what do you
say launch it
[Music]
that's very strong it's good enough it
tastes like my grandma's house I was
surprised how well it tastes it's
actually really get that's probably the
best one out of all of them so far I
don't it's actually very nice yeah yeah
what that how is that possible
I'm buying I think I expected points
emitted it's actually really it turns
out that you what they were doing I
wonder juice it turns out they knew what
they were doing we're Irish whisky is on
there in sauce on the right men do you
do you like it more than Japanese
whiskey no no Japanese whiskey is the
face really there's a pub in Ireland
that's like from 900 AD that's
ridiculous
and it's called Shaun's bear a and we
used to live very close to it and it's
right next to a castle well thank you
for joining me on this Irish special
episode and I don't really have an outro
do drugs kids don't do drugs drink
whiskey kids the only if it's 100 years
old
good bye bye